surprising research may help keep people
safe from the coronavirus in restaurants
as we told you these scenes are playing
out in some restaurants like this one in
Colorado now dining establishments may
need to consider air flow as well as
social distancing Omar Villafranca has
more on that
which crepes cafe in Dallas a restaurant
that once seated about 25 customers is
remaining like most restaurants in the
country
strictly takeout we don't even let them
order inside they have to order like
outside on the phone or online then
becomes inside besides employees but
some states are allowing restaurants to
gradually open in Texas they can't go
over 25% capacity yet owner Julian
Ellison says he's not ready to is that
for your peace of mind customers peace
of mind whose peace of mind like every
piece of mine my peace of mind my
employees peace of mind and my customers
peace of mind do you think people will
reward that loyalty I think I already do
actually a lot of customers give us some
very positive feedback it turns out
there's a lot to consider when reopening
a dining room and not all of it has to
do with keeping customers 6 feet apart
some of it has to do with air flow a
recent study out of China showed how one
customer with kovin 19 spread the
disease to nine others but look at the
pattern of infection some people seated
at the diners table and at the one in
the front and behind were infected but
nobody at the table next to it was when
a virus is caught up in an air stream it
has the potential that B to move much
further than 6 feet professor kevin
vanden y mellenburg and five other
researchers from the university of
oregon and university of
california-davis are the authors of a
paper focused on minimizing viral
transmission in buildings your team has
a 3d model of how it may spread we
created a conceptual visualization of
how the aerosols may be spreading in
that room with a with a fan that is
simply recirculating the air whether it
was an air conditioner or just a fan
moving air the visualization is really
trying to articulate how
the particles get caught up in the air
and move around the space the team
created a second animation for the same
room only with an open window yet less
people turn red and get sick
what did opening a window get right so
in this conceptual visualization what we
were seeing is that with increased
outside air exchange through the open
window particles deposit more quickly
and then also be exhausted from the
airstream more quickly
fresh air fewer infections are people in
the restaurant business is gonna have to
consider in the future in your mind what
kind of air conditioning system they
have it how it moves air I think we're
all going to be considering our air
systems and buildings much more
seriously moving forward and I think
restaurant tours will be included in
that scenario as for the outdoor dining
professor venden why mellenburg says
that it's safer than any indoor plan for
CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca Dallas fresh air fewer
infections absolutely fascinating thank
you Omar